You find something new to fight for.
Swear to me that everything you said about
the fireflies is true.
I swear.
Okay.
Welcome back everyone. This will be my Full Last of Us.
Episode 9 Finale Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references, so we'll break it all down.
Also, explain what's happening
with Last of Us season 2 because they've
already started talking about it.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
And careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
We'll start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments
because a lot of the episode
was very close to the actual
ending of the very first game
with a few minor changes.
They did wind up adding a bunch of stuff
at the beginning, especially
for extra context, just so that you know
more about the characters histories.
The episode title was Look for the Light.
It's a reference to the Fireflies
motto that you saw drawn
on all the buildings,
especially at the beginning of the series.
It's meant to complete
John Ellis Arc from the first episode
because the title of episode one
was the first part of the Fireflies motto.
When You're Lost in the Darkness.
So Episode one.
Episode nine is When you're lost
in the darkness, Look for the light.
Only this time the episode is mostly
about Joel versus the Fireflies R.I.P.
To all those fireflies,
he didn't kill every single firefly.
He just killed a lot of important ones.
The actual opening
scene is a big change from the games,
but it fills in a lot of backstory
and things that people had suspected
from the games for a long time.
It's of Ellie's mother, Anna,
in a flashback played by Ashley Johnson.
Big video game cameo scene after Troy
Baker's cameos in an Episode eight,
AC Johnson is the voice of Ellie
in the video games.
If she sounded familiar, if you haven't
seen her on screen before, your horses.
I want to see what all the fuss is about.
Oh, why are these all stuck together?
She does a
lot of live action acting roles
too, in different series.
She's running through the woods
from a runner infected, and she's
having contractions
about to give birth to Ellie.
Given Ellie's age during the present day,
the series, this scene would be happening
about 14 years ago, around the year
2009 on the show.
Just because the TV show
moved the timeline of the games
back about ten years.
So the present day of the series is 2023,
just like it is in real life.
The games pick up in the year 2033
before the fungus in 2003, Ellie's
mother had been a nurse at a hospital.
At some point
she became friends with Marlene.
Like she said that they've been friends
their whole lives before the fungus hit.
Then the fungus happens.
Federer takes over, and it seemed like
they've formed a version of the Fireflies.
It seemed like Anna
was part of the fireflies.
They're a group already.
When she got pregnant with Ellie.
Then about nine months before this scene,
she got pregnant.
And you see the events
play out on screen of her birth.
So this whole flashback to Ellie's
birth wasn't in the games.
It's another example, the show
adding a bunch of scenes for context.
In the games,
you never actually see her mother.
You only see the letter that she wrote
to Ellie to be given to her
when she was old enough to read it.
And she had made Marlene to promise
to take care of Ellie
after she died because she only lived
for about a day after Ellie was born.
The way that you see it
play out in the episode,
you notice when she runs into the room
upstairs to try and hide from the infected
while she's in the process
of giving birth, she sits under the tree.
It's meant to be a metaphor for Ellie,
like she's giving birth
to the future of humanity.
Like this green growing tree
just as the runner breaks into that room
to try and kill her,
she manages to kill it
while she's giving birth to Ellie,
noticing that she's been born
as the runner dies
because she hears the baby's screams like,
Oh, by the way, I was in the middle
of having a baby in the baby is born now,
almost as if she completely forgot
about the fact that she was in labor.
In all the chaos
in the even more WTF moment here
is that she noticed that she was
bitten on the leg like holy crap,
I need to cut this umbilical cord
before the infection reaches my baby.
But a lot of you probably saw this
and sense the same thing.
What the show is implying here
and this is a huge deal.
The games never actually did this
or took it this far.
They're implying
the source of Ellie's immunity
has something to do with the fungus
infection passing through her mother's
umbilical cord
while she was still attached to it.
So something about the way
her mother's body
processed the fungus infection
while it was traveling through the cord
changed it in infected Ellie,
but somehow mutated the fungus
to a different form
that causes present day
to kill the regular fungus when it tries
to infect her as Marlene explains
to Joel at the end of the episode,
like Ellie was infected.
But it's a good form of the fungus
that basically tells the other fungus
that it's similar.
So the other fungus doesn't
bother to continue infecting,
like it acts as a blogger
for the bad fungus.
And that's the key
to saving the human race in present day.
Finding out what that mutation is
in Ellie's version of the fungus
and how it fights off
or blocks the bad fungus.
They're trying to replicate that in
present day, or they hope that they can.
We watch her name, the baby Ellie.
We see Marlene and the rest of the
fireflies come back to their house there.
A little bit of time has come by
in the way
that Anna had been calling out
for the people.
Like I said,
it sounded like she had been part of this
early proto version of the Fireflies.
Remember, this is happening
about six years after the fungus hits.
They've been living under federal rule
for a long time.
At this point, it wasn't like this
was happening right after the fungus hit.
The other interesting thing here, too,
is that you don't actually hear
anything about Ellie's father.
The games never reference him either.
She mostly thinks about her mother when
she's thinking about her origin story.
So if you think you know anything
about who
her father was, right
that below in the comments.
There've been a lot of theories
about that too.
When Marlene says that they were delayed
getting out of the zone,
she's probably talking about the Boston
quarantine zone.
And this house is in the not too distant
surrounding area
because of the layout here.
You have to imagine somewhere else
in a different direction.
Nearby, there's Bill and Frank
living it up by themselves.
And this is meant
to be the rest of the story
of how Marlene came to care for Ellie.
The show is just showing how that play out
as opposed the games where Marlene
just told older
Ellie the story of how it all went down.
When she tells her about how she gave her
the pocket knife from her mother
and the letter from her mother.
The other big change here, too,
is that you don't see her mother write her
the letter that she gives her in the games
she makes.
Marlene agreed to care for her,
and she's the one on Anna's request
to kill her before she can fully turn
into a runner and succumb to the fungus.
But that's why, in present day, Marlene
had put Ellie in the federal school
because, as she told Ellie,
it was the safest place for her,
even though at the time she didn't
fully reveal the back story
and how she knew her since she was born.
Marlene also tells Joel about this later.
Like we didn't reveal everything to her
so that she wouldn't freak out
just because she has a grand plan for her,
because she knew that she was infected
and survived.
So she had been thinking this entire time,
like this 14 plus years
that Ellie been alive,
that they might be able
to use her for a cure,
but it might lead to her death.
So she didn't want to reveal everything
to Ellie when she was younger,
just on the chance
that might ruin things earlier.
Turns out that didn't matter
because Joel took care of that by himself.
You also noticed that Marlene
didn't tell Ellie that she was the person
that killed her mother.
That also probably would have soured
their relationship just a little bit,
even though technically
she was doing in a mercy like it was only
going to be worse for her.
So she was just putting her down
before things got too far.
Then you hear baby
Ellie cry out at the sound of the gunshots
and they jump back to Alien
present day outside Salt Lake City.
A little bit of time has gone
by since the end of Episode eight,
and she's still utterly traumatized.
Like she's just in this complete funk.
For the first part of the episode,
you can see how despondent she is
and how Joel tries to cheer her up
for that first little bit
there,
especially with the Chef Boyardee ravioli.
He found a big win for the team
because it's Ellie's favorite.
It's meant to be a callback to earlier
this season when she got all excited
about the Chef Boyardee
during one of their early camp outs.
And at the time, Joel agreed that it was
good and it was one of the first things
that they actually bonded over sharing
their love of Chef Boyardee ravioli.
That was very, very old.
Turns out it keeps pretty well
duly noted for the next apocalypse.
He also finds the old board game Boggle.
There is a real life last of us board game
called The Last of Us Escape the Dark.
And through this whole scene of them
walking slowly into the city, you notice
how Joel has started to treat her
differently now.
A little bit of time has gone by,
but we're talking about the last time
they saw each other.
He called her his baby girl,
and that was basically the moment where he
started to think of her as his daughter.
So you get more and more of that vibe
during their early scenes here
and especially later.
Once he starts to have PTSD flashbacks
to his own daughter,
it makes the decision to rescue Ellie.
There's a huge Easter egg for the games
when he mentions that he found a guitar
all smashed up
saying that he hasn't played in forever
and he needs to find a working one.
Maybe I could teach you, too,
because in the games,
both Joel and Ellie
play guitar and sing songs.
In fact, a lot of the songs they featured
in Season one, the covers of pop
songs, are songs that both of them
sing in the games and in the games.
It was Joel
that taught Ellie how to play guitar,
which you see her doing
during the Last of Us 2 game,
which will basically wind up being the
last of us Season 2 and Season 3.
So at some point between season one
and season two,
there's like a little time jump.
He will be teaching her
how to play that guitar,
but as you can see,
she's still utterly broke
and like she's barely paying attention
to him because she's so listless.
The fight with David
just broke her completely inside.
Joel starts breaking out the dad jokes
with Ellie, joking about blasting
through the rubble, the dynamite,
just trying to tell jokes and talking
about really crappy puns, asking for them
just to try and cheer her up.
The other joke
here, too, about Ellie's playing like,
okay, we're going to sneak around here
to this building,
look around the skyscraper
to get a lay of the land.
Is it a lot of the time in the video
games?
Both of the video games, the first one
and the second one you spend
sneaking around crab,
walking around buildings, trying to avoid
the other people there, their hostels,
the infected, so they don't see you.
But when it came time
to actually make The Last of Us TV show
because Pedro Pascal said he's
getting to be an older man,
it's much harder for him
to just walk around on his knees like that
the entire time.
So that's why on the TV show,
you don't see Joel
doing a whole lot of crab walking around
like you do in the games.
Blame the old man knees on that.
But even though they're trying to find
the fireflies, Joel is also still worried
about other potential hostile
humans or infected like other raiders.
It's a big city.
Like Salt Lake City is very big,
so they are infected there.
There are random raiders,
but the Fireflies
operation is so organized here,
like they've retreated their larger force
to Salt Lake City
that they actually spotted Joel and Ellie
the minute they hit the city.
So they just been waiting to pick up Ellie
because a lot of the fireflies
don't know who Joel is.
Only Marlene in a special group of people
know who he is.
So if all these fireflies just waiting
at the drop on them, not realizing
who Joel is
just because she is so valuable to them,
like the second
they get the drop on them later
they take her straight
to that operating room.
They waste no time at all.
Earlier on here, too,
when Joel is questioning Ellie
about being so quiet in particular today,
the other thing
that's going on in her head,
like there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on inside her right now,
is that aside from all the trauma
of what happened with David,
she also cares about Joel like her
surrogate
father, the same way that Joel started
to think of her as a daughter.
And she has no idea
what's going to happen to her next.
She doesn't really know what the fireflies
are going to do with her next.
She's worried about that.
Like, is this the end of her relationship
with Joel?
Her time with Bill?
Will she ever see him again?
What's going to happen to her after this?
Then she bolts when she sees the giraffe,
which is another huge Easter
egg from the games. He's his girlfriend.
Come here.
Hurry up.
Oh, I should doing. It's all right.
Hurry up, Mom.
So many
fans and so many people in my videos
have been asking
the last several weeks about the draft.
Are they going to do the draft
from the video games?
As a me posting this video?
I haven't seen the behind the scenes
of the episode, so I don't know how much
the actual draft here will special effects
and how much of it was practical.
They probably had a combination of the two
things that they filmed in actual draft,
but then they use special effects
to put the scene with them up close to it.
Images absolutely
blows her mind for a couple of minutes
and then she sees an entire herd
of giraffe living together,
which is the pick me up
that she had been waiting for.
Like she finally starts
to feel a little bit better.
The lion she speaks to Joel here,
pretty much this entire scene of them
with the giraffes talking about
the future is right out of the games.
After all we've been through
everything I've done.
It can't be for nothing.
After all we've been through
everything that I've done.
I can't be for nothing.
There's a lot of scenes like that
during the entire finale episode where
scenes are taken
directly from the video game.
Like the dialog
is meant to be exactly the same.
They also use a lot of music directly
from the video game too,
and Joel gives you the option
to completely forget about the mission
and just go straight back to Tommy's
and live out
the rest of their lives in relative peace,
which they pay off
at the end of the episode.
Obviously,
when he breaks her out of the hospital
and then lies to her so that she will want
to come back the time he's with them,
where she will be safe,
and he'll be able to protect her.
Unlike his daughter in test,
which he still regrets,
not being able to save the whole reason
why he wants to sell her on the idea
now is because he thinks of her like
his daughter and wants to protect her.
And he's also worried about what
the fireflies are going to do to her.
Because even at this point,
even though he doesn't know
that they're going to crack her head open
and basically take out part of her brain
and kill her in the process, he's
still worried
about what they might do, her line
about their mission not being for nothing.
They have to see this through to the end.
Also right out of the games,
she also references
Joe's Sheep Ranch again
and her wish to visit the moon.
And as they get closer to the hospital
area, Joel starts
remembering the events of 2003 after
the fungus started spreading and starts
talking more about his backstory,
which he'd been doing more recently
as he gotten closer to Ellie
opening up about his traumatic backstory,
where he explains what happened
right after the death of his daughter.
Like he starts
talking about Sarah's death.
No, she was already dead at this point.
I wound up in the hospital
basically because he tried to kill himself
unsuccessfully.
And this is meant to be a huge deal
because even just talking about Sarah
was probably the most off
limits thing to him ever before this.
He completely closed himself off from
the pain of what happened, losing Sarah,
what happened after the fungus said
that he'd avoided
talking about her in everything for years.
He didn't even talk about it
that much with Tess,
but his time with Ellie
has allowed him to slowly
open up that wound again
and start dealing with it.
When he also comes clean about what
he tried to do, killing himself to Ellie,
that it wasn't time
that healed all wounds.
It was Ellie herself that helped heal him.
And this is meant to be him telling Ellie
how much she means to him.
It also inform why he does some of
the things he does later in the episode,
killing all the fireflies to rescue her
because she's that important to him.
He's willing to prevent the chance at
finding a cure for the entire human race.
He cares about her that much.
She's worth more to him
than the rest of the human race.
He even starts crying a little bit
when he starts talking about this.
Just some dust in his eyes,
that's all. Just some dust.
Then after they start having so much fun
sharing awful puns from Ellie's
book of puns, they don't notice
the fireflies getting the drop on them,
which Joel had referenced in earlier
episodes,
saying that being with
Ellie had made him weaker, quote unquote.
Only that time he'd been talking about it
as if it was a bad thing.
And obviously
now it seems like a very good thing.
So the fireflies captured them
with the smoke bomb.
They take Ellie directly to their chief
surgeon, the fireflies chief surgeon,
who is Abby Anderson's father.
Dun dun dun.
She doesn't appear in the episode
or isn't referenced at all,
but she will be one of the main
antagonists in season two and season three
because Joel kills her father
while rescuing Ellie.
If you have played the games,
please don't talk too much about
what's going on with Abby.
I'll do a season
two video at some point
and talk a little bit about where
the plot picks up in season two
and how they're going to divide season
two and season three with the second game,
But they don't really get into Abby
or reference her anywhere in this episode.
For those people that are wondering,
Joel wakes up in another room
of the hospital with Marlene
explaining everything to him.
The rest of his backstory with their plan
is to do with her.
And this is all right out of the games.
Like Marlene explained him,
This is what's going to happen.
She's probably going to wind up dying,
but we're going to be able to create
a cure for the entire human race.
The idea, though, is the surgeon
taking out the mutated piece of fungus
in her that he wants to use
to create a treatment from will
essentially kill her,
like the operation will kill Ellie,
which is when the gears in Joel's head
start turning and he starts
having PTSD flashbacks
to the death of his daughter,
it's meant to be a parallel for episode
one when he freaked out on the guard
having the PTSD flashbacks to his daughter
because the guard was trying
to hurt Ellie.
And even though Marlene
is basically condemning Ellie to death,
it isn't meant to be them
showing her as a terrible person.
She genuinely hates that Ellie has to die
in order for this cure,
but she's thinking of the common good.
Whereas Joel is only thinking
about his baby girl like this
all goes back to the end of episode
eight. It's okay now, baby girl.
I'll take care of you As they escort
Joel out to the edge of the city,
She gives him Ellie's mother's pocketknife
as a way to remember Ellie.
Remember?
That's the same pocket knife
that we saw on Ellie's nightstand.
The reason why he stops
the sign in the hospital is
so that he can see where Ellie will be.
Like he can find out
where the pediatric surgery ward is
so that he can find her and rescue her.
He turns on the men in the stairwell,
and then the music sort of cuts out
and turns into more background music.
In all the music
for this part of the episode, Ray's mowing
through all the fireflies on his way to
Ellie is right out of the games.
You notice
that he even kills the fireflies
that surrender to him lay their guns down.
He even stabs one with Ellie's knife
so that they can't turn on him later.
Like I said,
when he enters the pediatric surgery ward,
the doctor here is Abby's father,
their main surgeon.
That will come back to haunt him,
killing him.
No spoilers about that.
Like I said, he does bury the nurses.
The first ones that he spared.
He pretty much killed everybody else
in the hospital.
R.I.P.
to all those fireflies
as he tells Marlene later
when he's in the process of killing her.
The reason why he killed them all
in such cold blood
is that they wouldn't be able to
turn around and come back after her again
in this whole scene
of Joel versus Marlene in the parking
garage is also meant to be
right out of the games.
And remember,
the actress who plays Marlene on the show
is also the same actress
who voiced Marlene in the video game.
So she's speaking the exact same lines
just ten years apart now in live action
plays.
You just come after
you just come after her.
Basically, the speech is another version
of the needs of the many versus
the needs of the few in.
The idea is that
Marlene is meant to be right.
The Ellie would want to sacrifice herself
if it meant saving the human race,
which is what Joel doesn't want,
which is why Joel continually lies to her
about what was going on.
Because he knows that
Ellie would want to sacrifice herself.
He just not willing to let her die.
I really like
the ending of the episode, too,
with the way they edited things, jumping
back and forth between him in present day,
driving away with Ellie, and then cutting
back to the scene of what happened
while they were in the parking garage
where he was killing Marlene,
if you like, the way they did that.
That's also exactly
the way the end to the ending in the games
where you're hearing his lies to Ellie,
where he's telling her what happened
while they flashback to show you the truth
of what actually did happen
when he killed Marlene,
it turns out there's a whole lot
more like you people that are immune.
They've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure.
It turns out there's a whole lot
more like you really,
people that are immune to dozens.
Actually, they've actually
they've stopped looking for a cure for.
The whole idea is that
he tells her the lie.
The fireflies don't actually need her
because they found tons of other people
who are immune like her.
And on top of that,
the doctors decided that
the treatment wouldn't work,
so they stopped looking for a cure so that
she wouldn't want to just turn around
and go back and find other fireflies.
He's trying to get her to completely
forget about the mission or the idea
that she could potentially be a cure
when in fact that's not true.
There might be other people who are immune
within the world of the last of us.
But when this first game is happening,
the game implies that she's the only one,
at least in the United States
or North America, that they've found.
I would say just based on random chance,
it's unlikely that she's the only person
in the entire world
who's ever going to be immune.
But the games have never fully explored
that yet.
Maybe if we see The Last of Us 3,
it just depends on
how wide the game goes, because most of it
is localized around the United States.
He lies to explain
why she's still in the hospital gown, also
setting up the idea
that Ellie will start to figure out
that he was lying before
she can get him to fully admit to it.
She does start to suspect something is up.
He tells her Raiders attacked the hospital
and killed everyone.
They barely got out
and implies that they killed Marley
like she asked, Is Marlene okay?
And he doesn't say anything.
Ellie
basically takes that the rest of the way
and just takes that as implication
that Marlene is dead
in the scene where he jumps back
and he finishes off Marlene
with a double tap second shot saying that
it's because she just come after Ellie.
Also directly taken out of the game.
They arrive near Tommy's in Wyoming,
and Joel starts remembering Sarah.
More like it's opening up more to Ellie,
even though he's lied to her.
Like he's kind of moving past that
when he says
they're very different types of girls.
Sarah
was much more of a girly type of girl.
I took that to be more of a reference
to the fact
that Ellie is a little bit more lesbian.
Sarah was not.
Sarah is more traditionally feminine.
Ellie's a little bit more of a butch.
And as they look over Tommy's settlement,
Ellie tells
Joel the rest of the story about Riley
and what happened.
It's meant to be a parallel for Joel
telling her the rest of his backstory
and how he tried to kill himself
and what had happened to Sarah.
But when she starts questioning him like,
you need to promise me again
that everything that happened
really did happen,
she starts naming off
all the people that she had cared
about and recently lost Riley
being the first one,
and he lies to her again, saying, no,
everything happened completely true.
There is no cure.
You don't need to worry about that.
We can settle down here.
We'll be safe
in Tommy's settlement, basically.
And when she says okay, it's
meant to be kind of a sad moment.
Like,
her reaction is kind of a sad reaction.
Where to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true, I swear.
Okay?
Even though she doesn't
totally believe him,
she's starting to figure things out
slowly.
It'll take a long time before
he fully admits what he said was wrong.
And at least right now it seems like
their mission had been for nothing.
Like all those hopes that she had
in curing everything like this
can't be for nothing.
But it does kind of feel like nothing
based on what Joel told her.
So it's more of a resignation on her part.
Like, okay, fine.
As of right now,
they do plan on making season two.
Pedro Pascal said they might start
filming it before the end of the year,
but he's also supposed to be filming
The Mandalorian Season
four around that time, too.
So we'll see how they work,
that schedule out
what they've said
is that because the plot of the Last of Us
two game is so much bigger
than the last of us, one game
that they'll probably break the last of us
two into a couple of different parts,
maybe two parts, maybe even three parts
across the next couple of seasons.
Also, there's the idea
that they want to go beyond season three.
They might adapt new plot that they do
for The Last of Us multiplayer game.
Neil Druckmann has also talked about doing
The Last of Us 3 game,
which they would also theoretically adapt
is their Last of us.
Part three.
No, no, no comment.
I'll just say right now
our focus is on
we have
we have the multiplayer game coming out
and we're going to reveal more
of that later this year.
So unless we had a really good
compelling story to keep the story going,
then we it ends up part 2.
I will do a much bigger
Last of Us season 2 video tomorrow.
But if he spotted any other Easter
eggs in the episode
I didn't mention in the video,
just write down below in the comments.
Overall, it was a great series.
I was really happy
with the way they adapted the series.
The last couple of years
there have actually been
some pretty solid video game adaptations,
so it does make me hopeful for future
other video games
being adapted to stories like this.
Speaking of Pedro Pascal again,
My Full Mandalorian Season three Episode
three Video will also post this week.
You can click here for that,
update the link as soon as I posted
and you can click here
for my Last of Us Season 2 video.
Also update the link
as soon as that post as well.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one